字幕: Youyou Jiang
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さんこんにちは
（観客）こんにちは
ちょっと足りないな こんにちは！
（観客）こんにちは！
ありがとうございます
櫻井亮太郎「THE 東北LOVER」と
書いてありますけれども
まずこの東北LOVERの話をする前にですね
この東北大学の話をしたいと思います
僕が14歳の時です
この東北大学には
外国人の留学生の方々
そして客員教授の方々が住む三条町に
留学生会館という施設があります
実は私はその近くに生まれまして
中学校は仙台市立第一中学校という
本当に隣のところに通ったんですけれども
実はですね そこで 決定的な
私の人生を決定づける出会いがありました
その客員教授の方々には
息子さん娘さんがやはりいるわけですね
同じくらいの 実は 14歳のですね
実は ポーランドから来た
パトリツィアという女性に出会いました
女の子と言ってもいいですけれども
また美人なんですわ
（笑）
中学校２年生にとっては
本当にショッキングな出来事でした
見たいですか？
見たい人？
（観客）見たい！
見せましょう ほら！
（歓声）
ね？
これ ダサイっすよね
（笑）
いつの時代ですかね？
多分ね これ 彼女と出会って
２年か３年後なんです
松島水族館です
今は亡き
で 僕の14歳〜15歳の遍歴が書いてあります
彼女と出会って 英語の壁にぶつかるわけです
彼女は日本語を全く話せませんでした
しかし 英語は喋れたんです
僕はその時中学校２年生
中学校２年生の日本人の英語は
わかりますよね
どれくらいのもんなのか
（笑）
「アップルペン」みたいもんですよ
そんなとき 彼女がやはり
私をヘルプしてくれました
どうやったら英語が通じるのか
英語の楽しみを教えてくれたんです
で その時 私は決意したんですね
「アメリカに行きたい
もっと英語うまくなりたい」って
そして僕は 15歳の時 アメリカ
シアトルに行くことにしました
なにしかったんでしょうか
僕はアメリカでね
英語がうまくなりたかった
あとねもう一つ プロム行きたかったんですよ
わかります プロムって
あの一番最後の卒業式の時 タキシードの
あれ出たかったんですよ
で いつ行くの？
今でしょう （笑）
という話だったんですよね
で 行ったのはいいんですけど
アメリカの洗礼を受けます
「いろいろ盗まれる」って書いてあるんですよ
（笑）
最初に盗まれたもの
安いスウォッチの時計が盗まれました
その後 ウォークマンが盗まれました
車盗まれました
まあ 見つかったんですけどね ボロボロでね
そういう 盗まれたんですけど
そこで やはり日本の安全 —
逆に 日本が特殊だったんですよ やっぱりね
財布を失くすと戻ってくるって
言うじゃないですか
でも 世界に出たらね
それは普通じゃない
逆に日本が普通じゃない
向こうが普通
でも そんなことがあっても
アメリカでは 本当に貴重な
たくさんの友達が出来てですね
僕は本当にアメリカで３年間の
生活を満喫しました
しかし この僕のアメリカの生活は
海外の生活はここで終わらないんです
というのも アメリカの
３年間を見た僕はですね
次の もっと広い世界を見てみたかった
ヨーロッパに行ったんです
次です
まず最初に 僕はアメリカに行った後
18歳で イギリスに向かいます
これ 作ったんですよこれ
ね ウォーってね
シアトルに行った僕はロンドン —
ほら あ ちょっと進みすぎましたね —
ロンドンに行った僕は４年間大学に通います
その後 最初の就職先はドイツだったんです
先ほど ４か国語 喋れるなんていうね
なんかブラフがありましたけれども
最近ちょっとドイツ語を忘れています
ですが そのドイツに２年半ほど
IT会社で働いた後ですね
私は何を思ったか
ダンサーになりたかったんですよ 僕
実は「シドニーダンスカンパニー」
というダンスカンパニーに
１年間所属しておりました
今はちょっと お肉が若干なんですけれども
そんな形で
それで１年シドニーには
ワーキングホリデーで行きましたので
１年間 ここで戻ってくるんですけれども
実は この中で私には決定的な
またもう一つの出会いがあります
次 ロンドンにいるときでした
ロンドンの大学に行ってたんですけれども
この大学の時に 私の友人でモロッコ人の
アハメド君という友達がいたんです
彼が僕にこう言うんです
「モロッコ以上の国はない」 と
「モロッコが世界で最高の国である」
「モロッコ料理よりおいしいものはない」
「モロッコよりもすばらしい景色はない」
「モロッコよりも素晴らしい人たちはいない」
モロッコって 僕その時
国の価値って経済指針だと思ってたんですよ
GDP —
その時GNPですかね —
が なんとなく国の偉い順だと思っていました
だから そのとき
日本が２位だったんですね 世界で
その話を聞いて 「なんだこいつは
何を言っているんだ？」と思いました
でも 彼に対して 僕 実は
言い返す言葉がなかったんですよ
日本が 日本よりもおいしい食べものはない
日本よりも美しい景色はない
日本より素晴らしい人たちはいないって
自信を持って言えなかったんですよ
僕が言えた言葉は これ
「僕ら トヨタとホンダがあります」
（笑）
これだけでした
そのとき僕 思ったんですよ
自分と自分の故郷を
これだけ誇ることができない
彼はできている 彼の勝ちだって
それで僕 日本に戻るんです
自分が日本人だというアイデンティティを —
僕 10年間海外に行っているんですよね —
この10年間で僕が忘れていたものを
取り戻すために日本に戻りました
東京に戻りました
なかなかね 10年間も海外にいると
ちょっとおかしくなってる 頭がね
日本人の中に 日本人の生活に
入っていけないんですよ
だから 僕は 日本の東京の
まずは銀行証券会社に入って
32歳の時に この「ライフブリッジ」という
今の現在の会社を立ち上げます
この会社を立ち上げた理由はただひとつ
この東北の魅力を 世界の皆さんに
知ってもらうということです
さあ この東北 どれだけ
皆さんに知ってもらっていますかね？
これ実は東北だけじゃなくて
日本の図なんですけれども
外国人が日本に来た数です
2010年からかけてみました
2011年は震災がありましたから
ちょっと下がっています
でも 見てください
29％ 47％ 21％というふうに
どんどんどんどん伸びています
去年2016年は 2400万人の
外国人の方々がこの日本に訪れました
さてここで 問題です
東北のまず図を出していきましょう
実はこれ東北なんですよ
青森 岩手 宮城 秋田 山形 福島
東北六県となっていますけれども
実は震災前と比べると
秋田 福島ちょっと除くとですね
大体増えているんですよ
すごく増えています
で 皆さんにこれ質問があります
日本全体に来ている外国人を
100％としたときに
この東北六県には何人
来ていると思いますか 皆さん
何パーセントか
いきますよ
50％ 半分が東北に来ている 来たことがある
10、9、8 —
（笑）
爆発しませんからね これね
7、6、5、4 —
3、2、1、0
あ 知っている方結構いるんですね
0.9％なんですよ
東北六県合わせてもですよ
この状況何とかしたかったというのが —
何とかしたい今でも —
これは私が 今もこの会社を
存続し続けている理由です
で ただこれを実現するためには
もっと人に来てもらうためには
僕らの力だけではダメなんです
だって１つしか会社がないんだもん
仙台にしか会社がないんですよ
力が欲しかった
ただ僕がこういうふうに
言い続けたんです
「東北にもっと人を呼びたい
もっと人を世界中から呼びたいんです」と
そうしたら 面白いことに
その目標を聞いた人たちが
いろんな人を紹介してくれるんですよ
あいつ 青森で面白いことをしているぞ
あいつ 秋田ですごいことをやっているから
櫻井さんに紹介したい
僕がこんなことを言っていたら
あいつと仕事すると
良いことが起こるかもしれない東北に
そんな出会いがありました
そこで僕が何をやったかというと
「東北インアウトバウンド連合」
という一般社団法人を
東北六県15社で立ち上げることにしました
これはどういうことかというと
東北で観光に取り組んでいる
15の会社が 同じ目的
東北に人を呼び込もうということで
立ち上げた会社です
実はこの目的なんですけれども
観光という力を使って
社会問題の解決をしていこう
どんな問題なのか？
少子高齢化
田舎と都会の給与の差
そういうものをインバウンドという
外国人の観光客を使って
この問題を解決していこうと
そんな思いで立ち上げました
どんなことやってるのか
皆さんにご紹介したい
僕らが いろんなツアーを作っています
最初にご紹介したいのはこれです
青森県は知っています皆さん
日本で一番寿命が短いんですよ
（笑）
見てわかりますよこれ
寿命が短い青森県人の
太くて短い人生を味わおうじゃないかと
（笑）
「短命県体験ツアー」
こんなもの作っていますうちで
この団体では
弘前なんです 場所は
どんなものか見たいですか このツアー？
「見たい」と言って
（観客）見たい！
はい ありがとうございます
真冬にやるんですよ
ちょっと見えてますね もうね
朝10時に出発しているのに
10時半から酒蔵行っていますよね
こんな感じです
（笑）
あさ10時半の光景です
酔っぱらって酔っぱらって
もう飲んでこう飲んだくれて
この酔っぱらってる状態で
お昼になります
お昼は
ラーメン 津軽名物の
煮干しのラーメンですよ
この先ほどカフェテリアでも
ありましたけれども
煮干しラーメン
でも なぜ青森県人短命なんですか？
ラーメンを食べるのに
スープ飲むからですよ
（笑）
全部飲んじゃう
これね実はこのツアーの掟なんです
全部飲んでくださいと言われるんですよ
（笑）
でもね 青森県人
これだけで終わらないんですよ
もう一杯食べさせられちゃう
（笑）
味濃いやつちょっとね濃いやつ
で またスープだ
（笑）
こんなことなんですよ
でね 酔っぱらって もう食べていますよね
酔っばらってもうこの頃には
けっこう時間だ
その後に 伝統工芸の体験
酔っぱらったままであるんですけど
その後に 旅館に行きます
旅館にもう4時半ぐらいに
チェックインなんですよ
酔っぱらっているから
もうやることないんでね
やりたくないんでね
そうするともう
布団が敷かれているんです
旅館の布団
普通は 旅館というのは
チェックイン時は布団は敷いていませんよね
そうすると 布団が敷いてあって
テーブルが横によけられています
そのテーブルの上に なんと
また 一升瓶と『人間失格』
（笑）
こんなツアーがあるわけです 世の中に
僕らは何をしたいのか？
今 実は 東北というとこは0.9％ですよ
この状態をどうすれば良いのかというと
北海道にもない
東京にもない 九州にもないものを
作っていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
皆んな 言うんです
「東北の良いところを教えてください」
「山の幸が美味しくて
海の幸が美味しくて
温泉があって」ですよね？
そんなもんどこでもそうなんですよ日本は
東北にしかないものをやっていくんですよ
だからこの他にもいっぱいあるんですよ
「マタギ」って知ってます 皆さん
熊を撃つ人たちでしょう？
マタギと一緒に山の中に
「マタギトレッキング」とかね
あるんですよ
あとね 居酒屋ばっかり
スナックばっかり廻る
「バーホッピング」とかね
いろいろあるんですよ
そういうもので 東北でしかできないものを
しっかりと 人を絡めていくんです
この実は 「青森県民という気持ちになる」
バーホッピングって言っても
スナックのママにちゃんとお話をする
マタギという人 暮らしぶりということを
体験してもらうことが
実は私たちが 一番東北で
やらなくちゃいけないこと
新しい建物を作るとかじゃないんですよ
今あるものをどうやって生かしていくのか？
そんなことを僕らはトライをしています
さあ とはいえ
外国人がたくさん東北に来たら
皆さん びっくりしません？
日本人の方々 緊張しません？
なぜ緊張するんですかね？
英語が喋れないからですよ
英語喋らなきゃって思うから
日本人はこうなんです
外国人が日本に来て
一番ショッキングな出来事は
道を聞こうとしたら 逃げられた
（笑）
向かっていったら うつむかれた
そんなことはたくさんある
だから 僕はこう考えたんです
まず皆さんの
心のハードルを下げようって
皆さんがしっかりと外国人の方が来たときに
ウェルカムできる心を作ってしまおうって
レストランでこんな文章があります
ありますよね レストランでね
外国人の方がこう注文した後に
「以上でよろしいでしょうか？」と
言うじゃないですか日本語で
こういう風な教え方をすれば
皆さん英語を簡単に喋れるん
じゃないかなと思って
これ実は一例なんですけれども
出してみました
皆さん 「以上でよろしいでしょうか」って
英語で何て言うか知っています 皆さん？
こう言うんですよ
ね？
日本人の発音だと
はい 読んでみましょう
せーの 「イズザットオール ？」
さすがうまいですね
（笑）
でもね これはね
１億３千万人の日本人の間でしか
通じない英語なんですよ
ですよね？
発音が日本語だから
じゃあ 別な言い方があるんじゃないか？
いきますよ
これから皆さんに一瞬で
ネイティブスピーカーになっていただきます
ほら
（笑）
[伊豆ダロー？]
あれなんだこれっていう話ですよね
いいですか このまま読んでください
最後クエスチョンマークは最後
お尻上げてくださいね
いきますよ せーの
（観客）伊豆ダロー？
ネイティブ！
（笑）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
（歓声）
心のハードルを下げるんですよ
皆さんが必要なことは
これを駅弁を売っている
おばあちゃんが言ったら
皆さん 一発で通じるじゃないですか？
英語が喋れる人はいいんですよ
喋れない人にも英語を
喋ってもらえる心を作るためには
これだけ簡単に教えて —
これは実はあとね30ぐらいある 30 —
こういう風なのがいっぱいあるんです
今日ね時間があと
５秒しか残ってないんでね
できないんですけれども
ということで 私たちは何をしたいのか？
私たちは何をしなくちゃいけないのか？
東北 外国人は関係ない
自治体は 宮城県とか青森県とか関係ない
面白いものがあれば
たくさん行くんですよ
狐村があればいくんです 面白いから
そして 僕らがしなくちゃいけないこと
県じゃなくて お互いが東北の民同士が
「秋田に行ったら
あそこに絶対行った方がいいよ」
「青森行ったら
ここ絶対行った方がいいよ」
「宮城に来たら あそこの牛タン屋
行った方がいいよ」って
お互いがお互いのことを褒め合うことで
外国人の方にも
「どこ行ったらいいの？」
「あそこ行った方がいいよ 」と
みんなが言えるようになるんです
そして 最後 今日は
学生の方がたくさんいます
ぜひ 教育 大学 高校
中学校 小学校の方にも
そういう東北の魅力ということを
お互いに話すように
英語よりもそっちが大切なんですよ
日本の歴史 日本の文化
日本の地域 日本の祭り
そういうことをしっかりと学んでいくことが
実は真の国際化だというふうに思っています
本日はありがとうございました
（拍手）